[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en el
marco de la cumbre climática que se
celebra de manera virtual y
semipresencial en washington dc eeuu hoy
nos acompaña
ernesto muy sound alcalde de san
salvador- alcalde gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 y le pregunto en
qué se va a comprometer su ciudad para
lograr cumplir la meta de neutralidad de
carbono para el año 2050
bueno desde el punto de vista de una
administración municipal y no solo debe
quedarse en la prestación de servicios y
acciones de la municipalidad
que nosotros prestemos los servicios
públicos de una manera sostenible y
amigable con el medio ambiente que
contribuye a cuidar en nuestro
ecosistema y recuperar lo que se ha
perdido con la degradación ambiental que
se ha sufrido en la mayoría de ciudades
y países en el mundo entero pues no
también debemos de liderar y ser la
punta de lanza los actores locales y los
alcaldes son quienes tienen una mayor
cercanía con la población y cuyas
acciones tienen un impacto más directo e
inmediato en la calidad de vida de la
gente que deben liderar a los diferentes
actores y sectores de la sociedad en el
lograr compartir la misma visión de
hacer todo lo que hagamos de manera
sostenible y amigable con el medio
ambiente que el desarrollo económico y
social de nuestras ciudades se haga de
una manera amigable y sostenible con el
medio ambiente creo que
a través de legislación a través de
incentivos fiscales pero más que todo a
través de dar el ejemplo a los actores
locales las ciudades juegan un rol
importantísimo y deben de tener las
herramientas que se las den el gobierno
central para poder contribuir en ese
sentido y tener un impacto mucho más
inmediato que lo pueden tener las
ciudades de lo que los tienen los
gobiernos centrales ahora alcalde le
pregunto por qué está disparada la
migración de ciudadanos desde su ciudad
hasta eeuu que el lugar hay para estas
personas que son devueltas de eeuu y
además le quiero preguntar si hay una
relación entre cambio climático y la
migración si es así le pregunto cuál
y la principal causa en este momento es
la búsqueda de oportunidades por eso
nosotros creemos que el trabajo de
nuestro país
en estados unidos que es donde emigran
la inmensa mayoría de salvadoreños debe
estar enfocado no en generar barreras
sino en construir oportunidades en
nuestro país para que nuestra gente
encuentre que su país
esas oportunidades de tener más y
mejores empleos en el salvador y no
tenga que ir a buscarla fuera de
nuestras fronteras y cómo hacer de la
lucha contra el cambio climático algo
atractivo para la economía de la ciudad
hablaba anteriormente de los incentivos
fiscales que creo que es una parte
importante pero más importante que los
incentivos fiscales es tener reglas
claras tener un marco jurídico y
regulatorio que permita que las empresas
y que genera confianza para que permita
que las empresas puedan hacer planes de
negocios a mediano y largo plazo y
puedan invertir más fácilmente con
cierta certeza jurídica que lo que hace
falta en muchos de nuestros países por
cambios volátiles
y las legislaciones o por legislaciones
que no se aplican o porque cuando hay un
cambio de gobierno sea municipal o sea
de gobierno central cambian muchas
políticas entonces creo que deben haber
más acuerdos de país en los diferentes
países donde las diferentes fuerzas
políticas se junten con las fuerzas
económicas sociales y la sociedad civil
para compartir una misma visión de hacia
dónde queremos llegar el país y hacer
esa apuesta verde que tienen que hacer
todos nuestros países por la
sostenibilidad ambiental y por cuidar
nuestro ecosistema alcalde mucho por el
timón yo quiero preguntar cómo les está
yendo al gobierno añadió kelly y cómo
podría mejorar la relación con estados
unidos una relación crucial para su país
creo que hemos sentado las bases pero
hace falta muchísimo por hacer y ojalá
exista la continuidad de ello dejó de
ser alcalde nueve días de nuestros
sucesores de continuar con la política
de sostenibilidad ambiental así hacerla
un pilar fundamental de nuestra gestión
municipal de eso dependerá que los
cimientos que nosotros hemos hecho
durante esta administración
y se le dé continuidad y podamos seguir
avanzando en ese sentido actualmente no
estamos listos pero hemos sentado las
bases para poderlo estar es muy pronto
si se le da continuidad a todo lo que
hemos hecho en ese sentido alcalde
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 ustedes gracias continúen con
nosotros
[Música]